شاب كان يعتبر الطفله المعجزه في عالم
العملات المشفره ذلك الشاب والفارس الابيض
كما يسمى خطف الاضواء بصعوده وخطف الاضواء
بسقوطه المدويه سقوط مدون لان منصته
الشهيره اف تي اكس خسرت في يوما واحد خمسه
عشر مليار دولار تتحدث طبعا عن عبقري تش-
تشفير سام بانكمان وطبعا يبدا انه هارب
الى جزر البهاماس لكن ما الذي حصل
بالتحديث
او غير حقيقيه لم يتضح الامر بعد الاشاعه
فادت بان منصه لن تكون قادره على دفع
اموال عملائها فتهافت العملاء وسحبوا سته
مليارات دولار خلال اثنتين و70 ساعه فقط
طبعا هذا التهافت اسقط من السقطه واسقط
ايضا الفارس الابيض واعاد تساؤلات حول
مستقبل كريستو نتعرف على قصه هذا الشاب من
البدايه حتى الافلاسرائي
من القوه الى التلاشي واعلان الافلاس كانت
هذه مسيره الشاب الحالم سام بانك من في
عالم عملات المشفره بانكمن كان المثل
الاعلى في سوق الاصول الرقميه بعد جمعيه
ثروه نواصلت لاكثر من 26 مليار دولار عبر
استغلال الفرق في سعر البيتكوين بين اسيا
والولايات المتحده
الشابره ليصبح شخصيه بارزه وغير تقليديه
لقبوها اس بي اف وشركه اختصارها افتياكس
تصل قيمتها السوقيه الى اكثر من 32 مليار
دولار لكن كل شيء تغير خلال الايام
المستثمرون يهربون رغم موعود بالانقاذ
والسيطره ليصله في النهايه الى ضربه
الافلاس القاضيه صدم العاملون في افدي
اكسبلنهيار الجميع كان ينظر للحرم المسمى
وهو الوحيد الذي نظر الامر من الواقعيه
وخرج للعلن وعلنا افلاس الامبراطوريته
وبقائه في مكان قامت بجزر البهاما بانتظار
ما ستصفر عنه الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
اسواق الماليه فرح مراد فرح يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك من جديد معانا بدنا اليوم نفهم
منك موضوع الكربته الذي حصل تحديدا يعني
المستثمرين في الصدمه انهيار دراماتيكي
لاكثر شركات العالم استقرارا في مجال
التشفير يعني لازم نعرف احنا مثل اي شركه
مثل اي انسان
او ما يعرف الميزانيه شو عليه مدفوعات
يكون عم بيجيب مصاري او من الاصول من
سميها بطبيعه الحركه لما تكون الالتزامات
عم ترتفع بطريقه اكبر من الاصول راح يكون
عن الوصله لما يعرف
وهذا اللي كان عم بيصير السؤال هلا كيف
قطعت كل هالمده وما كان حدا ملاحظ يعني
هلا اذا في همم هاعمل لها حذاء او عم
بيحكوا اكتر اكتر او اشاعات عشان نعتبرها
دلوقت الحاله لا تخلص التحقيقه انه كان
بينما ادور صاحب الشركه ان يكون عم يستعمل
اموال المستثمرين دون اطلاع وهذا المشكله
عم نشوفها بالقصور اللي بنسميها العمليات
المشفره او الاصول المشفره انه كل شركه
منا يمكن عم تكون واضحه كثير مع عملاقه مع
الانفسترز اللي عم يدخلوا على الشركه وين
ام وينهم هل هي بمكان همم نعتبره
باكونت مختلف او منفصل عن الشركه ولا هو
بين ايدين بشركه انها تكون عم تستعمل
طيب فرح اليوم صرنا عم نسمع اكثر عن افلام
العملات المشفره وتراجعات في سوق العملات
المشفره هل هذا يعني بدايه نهايه العملات
المشفره ولهذا كلام مبالغ فيه يعني فينا
نقول ايه لا يمكن الوضع بيشبه نوعا ما كان
عم نشهده خلال دوت كوم بابل اول ما بلش
التكنولوجيا الانترنت كنا عم نسمع كثير من
الاصول كانت او شركات عم ترتفع بشكل كثير
كبير ومن بعد رجعنا شفنا انه هي
هل هالشيب يعني انه وقت الانترنت هو منه
شيء مفيد بلا ولكن كلتك نال الجيد بده وقت
ليكون ع فعلا عم يمشي بالسوق بده وقت
لنكون عم نشوف قديه قادرين نستعمله قديش
هذه الشركه فعلا اقدر تقدم لنا خدمات تضل
معنا لفترات طويله ولا لا فممكن بيقولوا
في الامتحان وهان المراه او همم
هذا اللي عم بيصير عم شوف فعلا من بعد ما
وجت هالليفوريه بنسميها بالاسواق والسيول
العاليه هلا بنشوف مين كان عنده فعلا شركه
مدعومه او الاصول مدعومه كمان في حال
المستثمرين كان بدهن امورهم واي منك
بالاستفاده من هذه التراجعات بالشراء
والاستثمار فيها والبعض الاخر ينصح
بالابتعاد كليا على العملات مشفره انتيكه
كبيره ما هي نصيحه يعني نصيحه دائما تتعلق
بشهيه المخاطره
اكثر اكثر يكون معقول كمان الربح عاجباني
دلوقتي الحالي بتزن ان المستثمرين لازم
يكونوا عم يلحقوا التراند والله كل العالم
عم تحكي عن الكربته كرنسيز حدا عم يحكي عن
البيتكوين حدا يحكي عن الاتيليهم لازم
فعلا ناخذ وقتنا لنكون عم ندرس ما يسمى
بالوايت الورقه البيضاء تبع العمليات
المشفره بيعطونا فكره عنوان الاستخدام نحن
فعلا امنين بهالمشروع ولا لا هل فعلا
قاعدين كنا نحنا عم نشوف تطور بهذا
المشروع بالفتره القادمه لازم اوكي
تراجعات اعطينا فرصه ندخل باسعار اقل مثل
ما كنا عم نحكي خلال دوت كوم تراجعات
الكبيره على امازون مثلا لو الحدث سرقها
هلا استفاد كثير طبيعه الحال هيكون قادر
يستفيد من هذه الامور ولكن لازم يكون عم
نشوف هل هذا المشروع قالوا مستعمل هلا انا
فيه ولا بس عم بلحق التراند كثير ناس عم
يحكوا عنه مثل ما كان عم يصير
لكن فرح يعني طوال هذه السنه اكثر من مره
تصدر بيتكم عناوين الاخبار يعني بهذا
الهبوط المضوي والحديث عن الافلام
بدايه البرنامج هل يمكن ان يصبح سوق
العملات المشفره اكثر امانا في هذه الحاله
بدون هيدا اللي ناقص السوق العمليات
المشفره وهذا اللي عم يطلبه في اطالبه فيه
كمان ولكن شو المشكله انه العملات المشفره
المفروض اجت كرمال تكون عم بتغير مفهوم
التبادل المالي ما يكون في بسيط للتبادل
مالي لخصوصيه الماليه فطبيعه الحركه لما
يكون عم نفوت رجليكشنز اكثر كل ما بنفوت
قوانين يعني امور
بتنظلم الموضوع كل ما بنكون عن نقلل من
الخصوصيه كمان من الامور اللي خلت
المستثمرين يتوجه اصلا الاصول
المشفره فهيدي اللي يمكن ان نعتبر المواد
ولكن لابد انه نكون عن نشوف نوع من
التنظيم اكثر نكون بنشوف في تحركات بها
الدخان الكبيره عم شوفها عم نحكي من
تقريبا حدود 69,000 اللي بتكون اليوم
17,000 اكثر من 77% طلعات اظن انه لو كان
السوق اكثر يمكن محكوم او مسيطر عليها
مكنه شفنا الثقل كبيره شكله جزيلا دائما
لك هنا في الاستديو محلات الاسواق الماليه
لدى اكس بي مينا فرحنا